remembers how a quiet afternoon at a
shop to only do a day of death and
destruction
we were four men in the shop one of us
was seriously bleeding and injured I was
also bleeding it was dark it was black
smoke everywhere I managed to come out
of the shop and get help I saw a lot of
bodies and some wounded people crying
for help
most of the victims of Saturday's Car
Bomb attacks were women and children
the first explosion hit a busy
intersection at the heart of the capital
the education Ministry was the target
the second when ambulances and people
rushed to help victims of the first
attack
I was at the attack area when the first
explosion went off after that I ran away
I saw many dead people
al-shabab said the education Ministry
received support from non-muslim
countries and is fearing Somali children
from their faith five years ago the
armed group had attacked the same
intersection with truck bombs
500 people were killed in the worst
attack in somalia's history
who were these victims Somali people who
are recuperating from the al-shabab
attacks five years ago in the same area
some of them recovered from injuries
some were disabled some were orphans who
lost their loved relatives in previous
attacks and others
president Mahmoud who was elected in May
has declared an all-out war against
al-shabab and its finances but the
attacks continue
it just tells you that um shabab is
um being rooted out but they are really
uh uh a force to be reckoned with
um and it will take time for uh Shabbat
to be eliminated from the capital but
the work is ongoing
um now we'll see more attacks I am sure
just because
um of the ongoing government and and
Community Uprising that we are seeing
across the country
somalia's precedent says his government
is winning the war but for these
survivors Saturday's attack is yet
another reminder of a conflict that's
gone on for too long we're no place and
no one seems safe
Priyanka Gupta Al Jazeera